with the growing competition on YouTube
in almost every single Niche it's
important that you really take a step
back and look at what your channel is
doing and today I'm excited because
we're diving into Channel reviews for
all size Channels with myself and my
friend Rob from vid IQ and we're going
to be taking your channel live so if
you're here live welcome if you are
watching this on the replay I want to
encourage you to grab a notebook grab a
piece of paper because we're going to be
walking through some of the critical
pieces that you should have on your
channel and we know this from doing
thousands of Channel reviews over the
course of our career my name is Heather
Torres and I'm the host of the YouTube
Made Simple show and I'm excited to get
into today's episode
[Music]
thank you
welcome to this episode of the YouTube
Made Simple show like I said I'm Heather
Torres from think media and this is
probably one of my favorite shows that I
get to do here on this channel
specifically because we get to actually
be with the people and I want to welcome
today we've got true Mammy is here we've
got Sasha in the house uh Christianity
explained is here Nikki welcome to the
show I also want to welcome my co-host
for this episode and that is Rob from
vid IQ Rob how is your day so far hey
Heather how are you doing uh my day was
fantastic until I woke up and did that
terrible thing of checking my YouTube
studio and seeing that today's video
release is nine of ten yes it happens to
everybody I've been frantically changing
titles thumbnails trying to re-energize
it but oh well the weekend's coming so
I've already moved on so I'm fantastic
once again Rob thank you for being so
honest because that does happen right we
put all of our effort into this video we
hope that it's gonna be one out of ten
on the YouTube analytics you wake up and
Rob that should not be the first thing
you're doing by the way you should not
check the analytics first but I I love
that you are doing all the things we're
going to talk about today which is
trying to re-optimize that video so
really excited about that Rob you're
over at vid IQ tell the people who don't
know about vid IQ and you what your role
is there and um how vidiq can help them
yeah so I'm I'm the I call myself a
YouTuber in Residence at vid IQ which
basically means I make video contents
for vid IQ and vid IQ is a Creator
obsessed YouTube education product and
service we have tools that will
transform the way you navigate around
YouTube with analytics stats helpful
information and also now we're moving
into more of the uh consultancy side of
things where we're offering uh services
such as vid IQ Max which we're going to
talk about a little bit later I believe
um and I love how you said that Creator
obsessed that is that is a great way to
describe uh vid IQ and I would say I am
a vid IQ obsessed Creator so we're this
is a good match Rob I'm excited you
wouldn't believe how many years of
thought that value proposition took but
I eventually landed on Creator obsess
and I feel as if that represents both
you I and everybody who's watching today
so good well let's go to break down how
these Channel reviews happen uh Rob and
I are going to be randomly selecting
Channel reviews if you are watching live
over on YouTube if you're watching live
inside of one of our Facebook groups you
can drop your link there the think media
team is here and ready to grab your link
and if you have a question or you'd like
us to steer in a certain direction that
always helps us as well so if you really
would like some thumbnail review or more
like overall Niche review we're here for
that also
um we will let you know when we have
enough of these different channels to
um to review we're going to be going for
about an hour today Rob and I will
bounce back and forth and I'm excited to
jump into some of the reviews today also
if you've not yet already liked uh the
this video or if you've not yet
subscribed to this specific Channel I'm
going to encourage you to do that
because we do specific videos like this
every single week on this channel which
is our think media podcast channel so
love to have you be part of what we're
doing here skate to skate tutors thank
you so much for being here uh today and
let's jump into it Rob you've got our
first review of the day yeah so hello to
Travis Goodman uh congratulations first
of all on 200 subscribers and you are a
licensed physiotherapist with weekly
mental health content uh this currently
feels like a channel that's still in a
little bit of the experimental phase
um your content playground so to speak
I'm seeing a lot of shorts that you've
been creating a very much show in the
last month and that seems to have been a
conscious pivot from long-form content
uh previously I also want to say some of
these thumbnails are of a very high
quality it looks as if you've gone
through either a thumbnail Evolution or
you've maybe outsourced your thumbnails
to get a bit of help to design them but
they were looking at a higher quality
you know for the for the size of a
channel that you are and the videos that
you're making I'm encouraged by The View
counts typically you do tend to get more
views on shots anyway but if you're
getting 600 250 600 700 views for a 200
subscriber Channel excellent work
Cadence seems to be relatively solid as
well I'm looking at maybe one shot every
two or three days I guess the one
question I would ask here is
accessibility of content in terms of the
language that you're using
um in your titles for example what is a
vacillator anxious attachment style I
don't know if I've even pronounced that
right and I don't understand that from a
complete layman's term approach however
when I look at a title that says there
was one down here victim mentality okay
I'm more familiar with that term in
terms of uh if I wanted to learn more
about it so perhaps maybe there is a
somewhat of a barrier to entry for uh
all viewers I don't know if this is
intentional or not because of your uh
obviously your a professional licensed
physiotherapist you've got a lot of
knowledge but how do you make that more
broadly appealing to a wider audience
but we're in a very early stages here
Travis so I think it's all generally
very positive stuff and we're just
starting to experiment with shorts uh
Heather but I know think media has been
experimenting with them for you know I'd
say the last year do you think uh Travis
is sort of going in the right direction
here with a focus focus on shots to
begin with and then maybe going to long
form content later yeah you know the
evolution of shorts has been really
exciting in the YouTube world and and
really um it's been fun to be able to
experiment with different types of
shorts to see what's working what's not
working and actually YouTube just came
out because you know there was that
disconnect between short form content
and long-form content which was one of
our apprehensions even with the like
let's go all in on this short form
content
um I think he's actually doing a really
great job and one of the things that I
love about what short form content can
do is it allows you to figure out how to
get your message out quickly like
quickly and then you can elaborate on
that so you know we had Alex ramosi he
actually was just on the channel uh
yesterday and today uh he is a
fast-growing entrepreneur he is an
entrepreneur quickly growing in the
personal brand space here on YouTube
um and he said one of the really
interesting things about short form
content was he uh he actually practices
what hits in short form and then makes a
long-form video about it right so I
think one of the benefits of being able
to do short form content again is that
you can figure out like how do I get
this message out fast I did one that's
that's doing really well that's like
three ways to make money on YouTube I in
in less than 30 seconds I had to tell
three ways to make money with YouTube I
saw that that short was taking off now
I'm going to make a long form 15 20 30
minute video knowing that that is what's
right and especially in you know a
category uh like Travis is in here
licensed physiotherapist
um I think it's really smart here's what
I would say though Travis when it comes
to short form content
um you've got to hit the nerve write
this down everyone when it comes to
short form content you've got to hit the
nerve that's how people will watch
something over and over so how do you
hit the nerve what does that mean
um well funny that I say that and you're
a physiotherapist and that's like
strengthening your body but what that
means is like is there a controversial
thing you can talk about in your space
is there a larger topic that people
could be talking about in your space
that would be one shareable and too
clickable like you want those two things
to be really important so a lot of times
people start making short form content
and it's very very very Niche well that
doesn't necessarily blow up that's that
doesn't get you out into the masses so I
would have everyone try and think about
what is the nerve that you could hit
right now on YouTube what is the nerve
you could hit right now with your shorts
um I love Rob that you're showing even
those titling pieces remembering that
your title is critical to make sure that
uh it allows someone to want to click on
it is it enticing do I identify with
what you're actually putting out on
YouTube so those are just a couple
pieces uh but you want to make sure that
you are hitting the actual nerve of the
people anything else Rob I was thinking
when you were saying hit the nerve these
titles do kind of have a somewhat uh
challenging the uh almost like an
assumption like this person is a
therapist and he's maybe suggesting that
you might want to fire your therapist
because they're not doing their job
right and that's kind of a good example
of maybe the title hitting the nerve so
yeah I love it I love the way you um you
approach that Heather yeah and things I
I read that quickly I thought he was a
physical therapist this is like a
licensed like my therapist yeah
psychotherapist I do apologize that's
just me trying to read very quickly yeah
me too thanks for the correction I love
it uh Wendy said strike the nerve yes uh
definitely uh we had some people asking
how do I get a review well um you can
actually drop your YouTube link inside
of the chat we have Chris from the think
media uh he's our think media Community
manager he's actually in there uh
grabbing those links for myself and Rob
so that we can do these reviews for you
it is first come first serve and we're
just going through as quickly as we can
for as many reviews as possible next up
we have ask dave101
Rob when you just see this ask Dave 101
do you have any clue what this channel
is about
no I I see TR I see trucking school 2022
uh but I can't see any more also easy
trucking company jobs
all right I'm getting a little bit of an
idea now so it is something to do with
maybe getting a trucking license perhaps
I don't know what CDL means and yeah the
thumbnails are there are no trucks I see
I see truck as a word but I'm not seeing
truck as an image yeah so the reason I
asked Rob that right away and actually I
think media fam let me know did you know
exactly what this was when this popped
up and the reason I asked that is
because your YouTube home page it's it's
basically like your business card like
if I don't if I don't click on this and
know exactly what this is I'm out
because I don't know what ask dave101
with some red lights I think those are
red lights which would make sense if
it's Trucking but I'm more like can
there be a truck can there be like
something visual to help me really
understand
exactly what this is so Dave I know
you're just getting started looks like
you're uh hitting almost that 300
subscriber Mark I'm really excited for
you getting to that and looks like you
um are like again just starting right
now so about a year in of making content
and I want to encourage you to get uh
you're doing a lot of content very
quickly so looks like you jumped on the
bandwagon ready to produce content but
in the last five days you've had one two
three four five six videos headed out
and what I would say is when someone's
starting and you've got that passion and
fire to get your YouTube channel off the
ground I want you to think quality over
quantity write that down quality over
quantity because right now Dave you're
throwing a lot of things out and and I'm
not quite sure what's sticking yet
um so that's one thing that I would want
you to uh to be thinking about and when
I look at kind of the realm of different
types of content you've done I like that
you're actually going into the trucking
space when I think about we have one of
our video ranking Academy members which
is our program
um our Academy here at think media where
you can go deeper in your education of
learning YouTube uh one of our people
Tony he has a trucking YouTube channel
just past a million views on that
channel because he's very specific about
who he's speaking to he's talking to
other truckers I understand CDL to be
like a trucker license so I think that
makes sense for if someone is like doing
a truck or a license but here's some
videos you should do how to get your CDL
license now let me make this a little
bit bigger because I want to show you
just how many videos you could be making
on that exact topic how to get or how I
got instead of how to get how I got
my
my CDL license that would be like a
story you could tell but like how to get
how to get your CDL license how to get
your CDL license without school I don't
even know if you can did you get it in a
certain country the year uh Class A
right so these are just different videos
you could be making around this part
right here so trucking school uh I don't
know if you're doing
um
uh trucking schools that pay for
training I don't know if it's tips that
you're doing
um I don't know if it's like did you pay
for it or did you get a grant for it
these are just some videos you could be
making right away and then I know uh
from Tony who's on uh who's inside of
video ranking Academy he actually was
doing things like how to get Trucking
contracts because
um uh from what I'm knowing of the
industry contracts how to get Trucking
contracts with Amazon how to obtain a
trucking contract how to get
Transportation contracts how to get
government Trucking contracts I don't
even know Rob how I know this much about
the trucking industry as a homeschool
mom of three who does YouTube full-time
but I'm just here for all of the things
um what are you seeing Rob when you look
at this channel also uh for Dave
I I'm in a general agreement in the um
when you uh visit a channel for the
first time
as a viewer you want to know if you're
in the right place as quickly as
possible whether you should stay or go
and that's good for you as a content
creator you want the right people in
your channel watching your content you
don't want people who are fumbling
around watching a minute or two and then
leaving because they're not satisfied
and just through the presentation of the
thumbnails and the titling
it takes what I call
a little while to decode the content and
if it's not that instinctive aha moment
for the viewer then it becomes foggy and
I think this is a just a good example of
a channel that hasn't quite got its
packaging right in terms of its
thumbnails and its and their titles but
hopefully they'll get there over time
with more experimentation uh I think in
particular the thumbnails are what could
do with um some some work here and you
know as Heather was doing the research
uh you may want to just click on one of
those links and then just look at the
thumbnails and say okay
I'm not going to be able to replicate
these thumbnails perfectly straight away
but I can look at some of the elements
whether it be the text on screen or
quite obviously a truck on screen that
is it's the lowest common denominator
but things that relate to the you know
Trucking experience is what you want to
be doing on the thumbnail so that when
YouTube's sharing out to new audiences
they're gonna have that immediate aha
moment when they're seeing that
thumbnail
really good and I like to you know do an
analysis of like is this popular enough
to make a video on right and when I look
right here the helper trucker 59 000
subscribers he has over half a million
views on this one video over the last
three years how uh what is it how does
paid CDL school work 10 things you
should know before you I'm sure before
you go and I mean that is proof of
concept right there I mean this is
showing right away when I look up here
also young truckers D 8 000 subscribers
79 000 views on this video these are
things you want to be studying because
success leaves Clues so I would be going
through and figuring out what you could
be doing could you scroll up I just I
just bought something out can you just
scroll up with that so I was gonna add
here
um a lot of those videos were like a
year or three years old it's likely that
information has changed being updated
and look at this perfect example here
stack Trucking 336 subscribers how to
get your CDL 2022 nearly 10 000 views
that is a viral breakthrough moment for
them and that is something that the
Creator our hero could watch this video
and say well I can I know more
information about this particular topic
or I think he didn't explain this very
well I can iterate and make a better
version of this video yeah and I mean
even when you look at production value
he just looks like he set up a camera in
his truck and he's making a video about
this so how can you level up your
content to be different
um but that again right there showing
that this is uh definitely something
um this is a great one too this I mean
the Asian Mao show uh official Trucking
half a million how I became an owner
like I mean I don't know if that is your
story you would want to make sure that
you say that but really really
interesting and a lot of um opportunity
for you there uh for getting more viral
more views on your YouTube channel and I
would just say when I looked at that
channel also rob it was confusing
because ask Dave
um this this to me is the and I want to
do this and that and when I see Trucking
stuff and then I see fentanyl stuff all
posted within the last nine days you're
trying to reach two different people and
you've got to pick which one you're
trying to reach because right now those
two things are not actually the same
audience uh inside of YouTube's land of
trying to figure out who your video is
for well Rob who do you have next uh I
was just going to ask what did the about
section say uh oh good idea and see if
what is there anything well here we go
okay so One Stop Shop to future success
for whom how why
and and when you do that make sure you
define one very specific target audience
that you want to go after
whenever I ask you what your channel is
about and you say it's about this and
this and this or it's about this comma
this comma this remove all of the ands
remove all of the commas focus on one
thing for one audience at least when you
begin on on your YouTube Journey
yes definitely all right
so this might be the most unique
titillating channel name I've ever seen
humid with a Chance of fish balls tours
I don't know entirely what it means but
at the same time I also like it
usually I would recommend that channel
names be relatively shorts because that
means they're easy to spell easy to
remember easy to find but this one is so
off the wall
I don't know what do you think uh
Heather I was like okay the food is it
uh I I was kind of the same thing I was
like okay so it maybe it's a personal
brand eating through Hong Kong so that's
what I thought I was like originally
food they're just in Hong Kong
um but the name did not match that fish
bowls tours maybe that's like a thing
maybe that's like a a
Hong Kong Cultural thing maybe yeah I
love the value proposition as well eat
eat through Hong Kong's culture I like
the way you pitched that uh so the
channel has 12 000 subscribers and it
seems relatively healthy in terms of the
Cadence of your posts uh the views on
some of these videos are very
encouraging anything over ten thousand I
hear I I think here would be uh be
considered a success but there are some
spiky views on here and in particular I
look at this video from about two weeks
ago which is your first time going to an
anime convention and it only got 400
views which I think for the rest of the
channel you might consider that a
disappointment so the question is why is
that and I think my answer is just from
the packaging of a thumbnail and a title
is that you're doing something a little
bit different here you're not uh showing
your audience uh some of the cuisine of
Hong Kong you're going to an anime
convention and maybe I'm not here to
watch that type of content so I was
thinking like how could you merge these
two
ideas together and that you want to go
to an anime convention and maybe share
information about it but you also want
your audience to be interested in it so
my thought is you could have maybe
repackaged this idea of you're going to
try some of the food vendors uh some of
the restaurants bars or whatever at one
of these conventions to see what they're
like and that would be your pitch but
once the person is in the video content
you can then explore the anime
convention and have as much fun as you
would do in this video anyway it's just
I think the the pitch to the audience
could be a little different to keep the
regular viewers coming back to your
content because whenever you talk about
food in terms of going having a hot pot
or um
you see ah here we go so this is a good
example you're eating everything at the
Disneyland Hong Kong so you're merging
visiting a a tourist attraction with
your love for food I'm just wondering if
you were able to do that as well for
this anime convention one thumbnail wise
um for me personally I think the
thumbnails are a little busy on occasion
you have that tendency to use different
fonts with every single thumbnail that
you use and in most cases that font is
difficult to read so maybe a lack of
branding consistency although I do
appreciate that in this space on YouTube
there tends to be quite a lot of variety
from one thumbnail to another uh when
you're using fonts and and again just
from my point of view although
within different topics these strategies
can change a little bit I want to see
more of a food that you're eating like
you have a chicken hot pot here and I
can see that you're enjoying it but I
can't actually see that you can well the
chicken hot pot is in the background
I've just realized that as I've used my
magnifying glass but it's on a postage
stamp size it was difficult to again
decode all of the different elements of
this thumbnail but very encouraging uh
progress from this channel as a whole
yeah it's exciting to see this is why I
love YouTube so much Rob is I mean this
is such a uh for me I think this is so
cool it's probably her passion she
probably loves doing this she's bringing
uh more of the culture onto the internet
and I think it's just really cool when
you can develop into uh you can develop
a channel you know that can be something
that's supporting you that's one thing I
wanted to see Rob can we see if there's
revenue streams tied to this Channel or
if she's really making content right now
and AdSense is her number one way so you
want me to look into the description
here for any links
foreign
I can't see anything there's social
media links and points of Attraction but
nothing pointing to anything that might
be doing with an affiliate deals or
merch or a course of some kind
yeah that's that's one thing I would say
especially for a channel you know you're
over the 10 000 subscriber Mark which
means you have
what's called a micro audience you have
the ability to uh recommend Brands and
this is something um that I'm talking
more and more about for small channels
is this idea that there is already an
audience that is interested in what
you're interested in so how can you pair
that with a revenue stream onto your
channel most people are just doing uh
YouTube AdSense alone which is great
that's a great way to get started
however there are you know 15 other ways
that you could be monetizing your
content uh along the roads of building a
business around your YouTube channel so
I want to encourage you that if you
don't have a make money plan for your
YouTube channel that this week alone you
should watch at least five hours of
content of how you could be making money
with your YouTube channel because I see
a channel like that Rob and I'm like man
travel uh different travel sites because
people are going to be looking at that
content to travel there to actually
experience those things
um I I'm so so into this right now Rob I
just came back from a family vacation
where I probably spent 10 hours
researching what should we do what are
the prices of things how could we you
know enjoy this place where should we be
eating all those types of things and if
you have a channel like they do I think
it's really important that you really
think about holistically how can I build
this into a revenue generation for me
and my family so that this content that
I'm making isn't just an energy suck but
it also is a um it also actually is part
of your income streams as well so really
exciting for uh for that channel hey Rob
this is going to be a put you on the
spot question and I just need to know
Rob are you subscribed to the think
media podcast oh am I ever of course I'm
I'm here now on the thinkpedia podcast
channel so why wouldn't I be good I just
wanted to make sure you know sometimes
I'll look at my my like subscriptions
and I'm like oh my gosh I watched this
creators Channel all the time and I'm
not actually subscribed so I want to
take a minute I need to get a a little
sip of tea here and check out the think
media podcast did you know that we have
the think media podcast if you liked
this episode you can get more just like
it over on the think media podcast
that's where Sean candle and myself go
deeper in topics like how to become a
YouTuber the struggles are real of being
a content creator and we interview our
industry expert friends bringing you the
best information right now to help you
grow and scale your YouTube channel so
if you want to join us over on the think
media podcast you can find us over on
that channel at youtube.com think media
podcast
well we can make this even easier for
those who are watching this particular
stream Rob because you're on the podcast
right now so if you're not subscribed we
are trying to get to a hundred thousand
subscribers get another silver play
button uh for this channel specifically
so if you are not yet subscribed I'm
gonna encourage you to subscribe so that
you can actually be a part of what we're
doing here at think media on a deeper
level
um we bring people like Rob on we do
Channel reviews and uh we have so much
content that we have here um on the
shows so Rob I've got a really exciting
one um I've got casual di excuse me
casual DIY uh congratulations 40 000
subscribers already
over here on the channel and I know
exactly what I'm getting casual DIY I'm
going to learn get inspired and create
uh so great job with that and I want to
dive a little bit deeper into kind of
the channel setup uh that this channel
has and that first is right up here in
these buttons now
um having the subscribe up here in the
banner and having the Subscribe right
here are you're just double dipping
basically you want to use this for where
they should go next so where they should
go next
um I see here is right into your
membership right if you have the ability
to have a membership you can actually
use this here this line here uh to give
a call to action that would bring
someone deeper into your world now most
people don't know what this little dot
was I didn't even know what this little
dot was so I think it's really cool that
when I clicked on it I was like oh I can
go right over here I can be a part of
your community at a deeper level I can
learn more and looks like you are um
creating membership based content so I
would actually go through and re-update
this because that's going to help and
then I see like your face here and I was
like oh my gosh that's your website okay
well I need to know that that's your
website before I get this far down so
deciding where you want someone to go is
really important and using this part
here which is your channel Banner to be
a place where you could say you
literally could type the words in here
like uh join my community here and make
a little arrow that goes down and then
they can click on it and then it could
say uh interested in new products go
here and you could have an arrow that
goes there and that just helps someone
right away see within the first five
seconds of joining your channel seeing
your channel here on the home page uh
what they can actually do to go deeper
with you so that's number one number two
is um when I look at your thumbnails
um one thing is I like this one here DIY
garden stool uh for a couple reasons you
have a contrasting colors inside of this
thumbnail and it's very very clean when
I go over here this thumbnail
specifically to me I I'm the product
that I'm getting is very far away and I
can't even really see what I'm getting
so I understand that this is like a tool
this is like the tool that it does the
Engravings and then these are the
Engravings but I want to see this up
close I want to see way more
um of that than than what I'm seeing
here this also is the same thing this is
a lot happening in this I know that you
are giving a review of this product
um but this is really far away to see
what the outcome of that product is so
going in deeper uh with your thumbnails
could be something that could help you
um on your channel again if I go over to
the about page here
great job because I get a little uh
right away I get that you are a
self-taught woodworker
um you are polish which is awesome to
actually see culture uh um linked into
that and I think it's really cool that
you have that however I want to know
like can I work with you what do I what
do I need to know next um join my
community as an Amazon associator
qualified so uh purchases that you make
from my Amazon links will help with this
channel this to me is something that
would go in your description it of the
video it doesn't have to actually go
inside of your about page
um part of what you're doing here so
that would be number one and then when I
go through and I look at um some of your
stats here
um three videos out this month and less
on the views so when that happens I like
to look at okay well what does it look
like over the last three months let's
look at the last three months and this
is a cool tool
um from vid IQ actually that helps me
actually see more of what's happening
over the last three months so I can see
that the content you're creating either
you did a Content pivot right maybe you
you've switched in the type of content
you've created or you're not creating
content that people want to watch
comparative to the other content that
people were watching so I'm just kind of
looking around on what you've been doing
and I see that you've definitely gone
down uh the uh
order what would you think Rob or or
tour I'm not I'm not familiar with what
that is but if I look at just the last
three months of the type of content you
were making prior to versus the kind of
content you're making now it looks like
you went away from some of the just
basic DIY larger like this is a foldable
ladder shelf 5K views on that one there
even when I look at this one here this
is a very clean uh thumbnail this is
very uh Deep Reach clamp
um so that is something that you're
making so just thinking about the
content uh that you are creating you
could actually be going a little bit
deeper into that let's see if there's
anything trending I'm just clicking I've
vid IQ installed right now and I can see
um just some different stats and
trending that's happening uh on your
channel let's go to the most popular
videos because success leaves Clues and
it looks like over the last several
years you've been creating great content
that's getting a lot of views use so
have you made a part two to that content
um when I look at something like this
this workbench with a flip top miter saw
station all in one this was made three
years ago I would like to know how is
this held up over three years have you
made that video because if someone's
interested in making this they probably
want to know wow did something break on
it is it still working is it still your
favorite workbench what does that look
like for you so you've got a lot of
successful videos that you did in the
past and I would be thinking what are
some of the adjacent videos you could be
making directly related to that
Successful video because as you are
creating content and as that video is
getting Steam on YouTube you could have
another one writing the coattails and
that could lead someone to actually
watching more of your content rather
than just one video at a time anything
specific you're seeing Rob uh I'm still
caught up on the channel then on the
channel
casual DIY
I look at the thumbnails and the
products that they're reviewing and the
stuff they're building and this feels
more like hardcore passionate uh quite
skilled DIY uh and and again I don't
know if I'm just getting caught up on
the channel channel name there
um but yeah I mean this person is
clearly very talented at what they do
and as you rightly set out the most
popular ones epoxy resin has been a
successful Topic in the past and I
couldn't see any content recently I
think on that topic so maybe revisiting
uh that as well and you know it does it
does I'm trying to think of the ideal
um
viewing candidate here you look at DIY
Gardens if you just go to the top
Heather the one on the right hand side
which says DIY garden store with storage
that seems fairly logical like what I'm
gonna make here and this is how I'm
gonna make it versus the auto laser
Master 3 review Plus testing in a very
specific piece of equipment
so it feels as if it's going from a very
approachable content that maybe anybody
could watch and get information from to
I guess maybe with the laser Master
stuff for some affiliate sales going on
there and maybe you've been sending
products for review I don't know we've
not watched a video
um but maybe there needs to be uh just a
a strategy session to sit down and say
okay who is my ideal
um audience member it's somebody who's
been doing DIY for maybe six or seven
months already the bought some equipment
but they haven't gone into really
specialized equipment they're willing to
spend ten thousand to twenty thousand
dollars per year on this um on this uh
passion
I feel as if your con intent is already
aligned with that it's just again the
channel banner and the channel name
which was throw me off a little bit yeah
and I do like that you know he did post
the latest one he posted today actually
was his channel update so without
watching this video
um obviously we're giving our own
critique based on just what we're seeing
uh but I see that you do have Channel
update and I really like how you just
said that Rob because with a Creator
like this you know he's been creating
content for about four years
um there's Evolution as a content
creator and there's even an evolution of
exactly who you're making content for
and I think that's really key to you
know once a year really step back we we
have this inside of our Niche Finder
course and we tell people once a year
you should step back and just reevaluate
where's this going who is this for what
are the revenue streams I'm trying to
accomplish with this and actually what
is the outcome I want with this YouTube
channel because sometimes you can get in
just the content creator rut and all of
a sudden you're like wait where am I
going am I going north or south like
what what am I even creating here and it
could be a really uh really key to a
content creator who's been doing
something like this for four years to
reevaluate that do you guys do that at
vid IQ often Rob
we should do it Melvin we do to be
honest uh but yeah I think we can't
we've kind of fallen into this certain
audience that we appeal to which is
generally creators under a thousand
subscribers four thousand hours of watch
time working towards monetization
and they are 50 likely to be a gamer or
another type of Channel and that's where
we're currently at
um but you know what I think it's a it's
it's about time for us to do the um
re-strategizing
um points uh as we have had uh and and
like a new influx of audience recently
in the last two two months our views
have been significa significantly up so
we'll probably need to do research into
who's discovering us at this at this
point really good I love that and Daniel
asked this question I thought this would
kind of relevant to even what we're
talking about right now garyvee talks
about business social media nfts
collectible cards garage sales a lot of
topics at the same time Rob why is this
not something especially with the
audience that you guys really are
reaching on vid IQ why is this something
you wouldn't recommend for a brand new
content creator because the topic of
garyvee is not social media nft
collectible cards garage sales it is
Gary Vee he is the magnetic force behind
all of his content and I think
ultimately what every Creator wants to
do is to be known for themselves as a
brand as a personality etc etc but
generally speaking when you first start
creating content the value is your
content as opposed to yourself because
unfortunately viewers tend to be quite
selfish and say what's in it for me I
don't care who you are I just want to
extract you know extract the value of
your content but once you get somebody
into a video and then you can share a
bit of your personality your
entertaining skills your comedy so on
and so forth that's when people start to
get you to know you a little more
personally and you know garyvee what was
his first Niche and topic it was selling
wine as far as I can remember yeah Wine
Library so that's what he was first
known for and look at those terrible
thumbnails whatever happened to him
just crazy and this is I think the part
that people don't actually do their
research on yes garyvee now
16 years later 16 years not 16 days not
16 weeks not 16 months because he was
actually being a content creator 16
years ago about things that people
weren't actually getting on to watch
Gary people were getting on to see the
review of the Pinot Noir goes sideways
in Chile like people were getting on
because he was actually doing reviews on
wine and here's the other thing I want
people to see garyvee's Channel right
now Rob is pulling in million tens of
millions of views right but we'll look
at would you look at this 1.5 K views 2K
views 6.5 K views 2.4 K views this one
right here really popped off 322
000 views 3.3 000 views so I understand
that the Allure of YouTube right the
Allure of becoming a social media Guru
or becoming you know a personal brand
feels like it should happen overnight
Daniel feels like it should happen
overnight Dave and uh and
um and uh who do we have Tomas like it
feels like it should be happening a lot
faster but I just want you to see here
that this started with one channel
talking about wine over and over and
over and over and I think this is
something that a lot of creators want to
skip they want to skip the 3.2 views
they want to skip the 6 000 views the
500 views
um but this is actually where you get
the establishment of becoming a content
creator this is actually where the
growth happens as a content creator so
pick your Niche pick who you want to
talk to Daniel and go all in on talking
to that specific audience because over
time you'll then be able to talk about
more things you know I know that Rob you
are very passionate about YouTube
specifically but that's not your only
passion right like you have other things
in your life that you probably we could
be talking about on YouTube but you keep
it very specific to talking about vid IQ
correct yeah I am a closet uh 1990s
wrestling fan like I listened to hours
upon hours of podcasts
um but other than a few impressions of a
rock and like sometimes displaying my uh
wrestling belt there uh I I think Pat
Flynn is very much uh a uh I'm
Ambassador for this point of view
because I remember when I interviewed
him at VidCon he was telling me how like
bats of a future is his favorite film of
all time
um and he incorporates it massively into
his content but it's not the focus of
the of a marketing pitch to to the
viewer he's just sharing that he is a
human being and he has of interests once
people are within his video content
yes definitely so just wanted to really
hit that on uh today's podcast rob you
are though the lead content creator The
Connoisseur of the content over on vidiq
you are one of the reasons why vid IQ is
over a million subscriber Channel and
one of the I think one of the best
softwares to have connected to your
YouTube channel as a content creator it
is the biggest tool that I use in my
tool belt Rob but can you tell us just a
little bit about vid IQ for those who
are not yet a part of the vid IQ
Community well thank you however I'd
like to think I'm the only reason that
we have a million subscribers but now
I'll I'll take some contribution to uh
to Our Success yes so
I joined vid IQ because I started using
their tools six or seven years ago when
we had the
um copy tags feature it made it very
easy to find out what other tags were
being used by creators copy them and
paste them into our own videos the
software's moved on a little bit since
then we're now moving into the AI space
so for example when you start your
channel you download vid IQ we'll start
to analyze your content and suggest
video ideas up to 50 every single day if
you're on our top boost tier which I
think is a free trial about that I'm
sure Heather will tell you about in a
short while once you have the idea and
you've made a video how do you turn that
into a really clickable title again
we've got the title generator which is
going to make a curious headline
grabbing title but we don't just have
our tools anymore we're now moving into
more of the personal coach approach
whereby we become your your Mentor your
trainer the person sitting on your
shoulder tapping you on the head and
saying you're doing a really good job
you've got to keep pushing through
you're gonna have bad days you're gonna
have good days but YouTube is a marathon
not a Sprint and so that's where um we
talk about our relatively new service
called vid IQ Max I don't know if you
want to just share my screen for a
second however uh where
we realize that once you are maybe
monetized and you're getting some income
from your channel how do you reinvest
that back into more development of your
skill sets and education and so what we
have at vid IQ Max
is a cohort of students uh hundreds now
who are attending uh bi-weekly often
more more regularly than that but we
commit to bi-weekly training sessions
with industry experts so previously
we've had on people like Jake Feldman
sharing his insights into YouTube shows
we recently had on Jake Thomas who gave
us the inside track on making really
curious titles that get clicks but
beyond the training sessions we have a
growing Discord Channel which is just
incredible we've got peer-to-peer
learning we've got coaches in there also
offering their advice we even have
through their own volition we didn't
like demand that they do this we have a
YouTube employee who just sort of sits
there stealthily in the background uh
listening to all of these questions and
answers and then just dropping in at
random with knowledge bombs say yeah
that's kind of true but it actually
works like this so to have that
knowledge religion insight and the
Discord channel is amazing and from what
I hear Heather you are going to be
making your first appearance on the vid
IQ Max sessions very soon yeah what are
you going to be talking about yeah so uh
we actually had the second edition of
YouTube Secrets drop which is Sean
kennel's book and one of the newest
chapters inside of that book is all
about the perfect video recipe so I'm
going to be for the first time sharing
it exclusively inside of the vid IQ
community of just the uh what we've seen
over hundreds of thousands of videos of
what actually creates a winning video
and there's certain pieces you need in
that recipe you know like when you bake
a cake if you omit the sugar from the
cake it is not a good tasting cake and
the same thing applies for YouTube
videos you've got to make sure you've
got all the right ingredients in it
whether it's an entertainment video
whether it's an education video whether
it's a tutorial video or it's a reaction
video there are certain pieces that
should be in every single video so I'm
going to be sharing that exclusive
inside of the vid IQ Max Community yeah
and so when you attend one of those uh I
guess what you call it a virtual
conference but it happens on a regular
basis uh Heather will do a fantastic
presentation and then there'll be a q a
afterwards as well if you want to ask uh
Heather and other experts for
information so it's simply called vid IQ
Max as well as all of the
um
peer-to-peer and personal connections
and and coaching you get you also get
Oliver vid IQ tools on top as well so
vid IQ boost is uh included with vid IQ
Max so yeah do check it out just search
for IQ Max uh if there isn't a link in
the in the description here on Google
you should be able to find this page
so so good well thank you Rob and um
also if you're not already a part of vid
IQ you can go to uh vidaq.com forward
slash think and you can get started uh
with some really incredible tools uh
that are happening over on vidiq Rob
let's get into one final review but I
just want to encourage Vaughn here
Vaughn says is an 18 click-through rate
good or not it was 32 days ago I would
say Von that is a phenomenal click the
great uh when you're looking at the
overall
um as more and more people are coming
into YouTube uh and you're making more
and more videos 18 click-through rate is
incredible Rob what what's your take on
this
yes but it depends on the sample size
that's true for example if you're a
brand new channel and you have a hundred
Impressions and a click through rate is
18. that's good but it's probably not
enough yet to start triggering more
recommendations
um
now one thing is like you say it was 30
two days ago now it's 18 well that might
actually be a really good thing because
YouTubers shared your content out to a
lot more people and tested it with new
audiences and as it tests with new
audiences less people will click but
it's sharing it with more or more um
more of an audience I always answer this
question like this would you prefer to
have a thousand Impressions
um and 50 click through rate or 10
million impressions and a click-through
rate of five percent if you quickly do
the math you prefer a lot more
distribution of your content so
on an individual basis it's very
difficult to answer this question but 30
18 do sound like relatively positive
numbers
yeah I think you're right Rob I was
making a lot of assumptions by reading
that one thing
you have to do it with these sort of
individual uh data points yep yep so
good all right well Rob let's get to uh
your final Channel review here today and
um if you didn't get a channel review
today no worries we are here all the
time and actually over on the vid IQ
Channel they're doing weekly Channel
reviews as well so Rob we've got the
gaming mum which I'm sure Rob mom is me
she she's uh she's your people right she
must be a Brit yeah uh if she's a mum uh
as opposed to a mom and also uh
full credit to you for not only being a
mum but playing video games and having a
YouTube channel as well there's a
there's a lot going on there uh with
your busy life here's a question though
you are a gaming mum and I think that
puts you in quite a unique probably
underserved part of the YouTube
landscape because there are so many
gaming channels but you're a gaming mum
and that means that you can Target a
very specific audience there are likely
tens of thousands of gaming mums out
there so you should be appealing to them
but when I look at your thumbnails and
your titles it doesn't look as if you're
doing that really at all from what I can
see
I am seeing some tutorials about how to
set up parental controls through a
Nintendo switch that might be something
that a parent is concerned about
absolutely
but in terms of a thumbnail and a title
I feel as if it could be a strong uh
emphasis on you know protecting your
children through these parental controls
I also see something that really
concerns me just because through all of
the channel audits we do every single
week we see this time and time again and
we worry that this Creator is going to
be exactly the same place this time next
year and it's these let's play style of
content now there's nothing necessarily
wrong with doing let's plays if that's
what you're passionate about and that's
what you want to share with your
Audience by all means go ahead
however this is one of the oldest and
most oversaturated topics on YouTube and
so if you're gonna have a thumbnail that
simply says Let's Play episode three
stardew Valley which is quite an old
game unfortunately there are likely tens
of thousands if not more creators who
have attempted to do this in the past
there's probably still a couple of
hundred around who do it successfully
but thousands have failed because of
this type of strategy in that you're not
telling me what's happening in this
video I don't know other than you're
playing this game I don't know what part
of the game you're playing if anything
dramatic happens if you have solved
anything in this particular game
how do you make this more exciting to me
who's encountering your content for the
very first time to get me to click and
on top of that you're jumping through
quite a lot of topics stardew Valley
Fall Guys little witch in the woods
Pokemon uh what else we've got Persona 5
knockout City I know those videos are
over a year old as well so that's
something to consider in terms of
Cadence as well yeah just looking at the
top row of videos you're posting a video
what about every month at this point
gaming channels in terms of their
Cadence tend to be
more regular but I know you're a gaming
mom so when you think about how often
your audience is probably watching I
would guess a gaming mom maybe watches
YouTube once a week on a Sunday night
when everybody's gone to bed and you can
have a little bit of r r maybe with a
glass of wine hey check out garyvee's
channel if you want to learn more about
wine but yeah maybe if you can commit to
one video a week on a particular game
that you like to play and I'm thinking
of like Animal Crossing stardew Valley
maybe the Sims I think those are all I'm
basing that off of what my wife plays in
terms of what female Gamers tend to
enjoy playing so apologies if I'm
stereotyping a little bit there but at
the same time as that you know
how are you going to make them more
appealing to your target audience
because when I quickly Mouse over the
thumbnails I'm not seeing you in the
videos either you know you can maybe
record yourself film your reactions
essentially what I'm all saying here is
right now you're a gaming channel with
the type with the channel name the
gaming mum how do you make all of your
content appeal to that particular target
audience
that uh one of the things I'm seeing Rob
too I was confused I was like oh the
gaming mom so I thought oh she's either
teaching parents about gaming or is she
playing games and so I was originally I
was like okay which one is because it
says reviews commentary and more uh so I
mean there is an audience for both and I
think that's one of those things you
have to decide at the very beginning are
you who is your audience who are you
actually creating content for because
that's going to determine the way that
you go into making your content
um really cool I think she's also using
uh canva that was canva so that's really
cool to see making little videos from
canva that was a long intro though like
come on come on get on with it this it
was six seconds in now show me the game
yeah you could start right there yeah
yeah yeah
definitely
um yeah and and going to a ton of
different games and just starting out so
I think this is great you know you're
experimenting with different things so
that's why we're here we're here to help
we're here to coach we're here to uh
help you move forward in um in what
you're doing and look there's a there's
a person for you Nikki B I'm a gaming
mom and I do Roblox games so awesome
really excited uh that you are here as
well anything else on this channel Rob
I was just trying to sort my most
popular to see if it was a particular
game that was picking up traction so
no I don't think anything's really taken
off of the channel yet the the most
popular one was from over a year ago
uh so yeah you still have this uh you're
still in this um exploratory phase at
this point of finding finding your home
on YouTube
um but I guess what I what I don't want
to see is in a year's time you have
video titles that are let's play a game
episode 94 walkthrough
it's just been done so many times and
it's such a functional way of describing
content as opposed to making it very
exciting to watch and we've seen
channels do this for years and years and
years and they've made a thousand videos
and they're still getting less than 10
views per per video and I don't want the
same thing to happen to this creator
foreign
yeah I see that over and over and again
yes when you're in that exploratory
phase it's fun to make videos it's fun
to do that but really it's figuring out
you know what what do you what do you
want the end outcome of this to be so
really really exciting well hey Rob we
are at the top of the hour I am or top
of the half of course yeah watching live
um I want to thank you rob for coming on
for sharing your expertise uh for what
is happening um here on YouTube so many
great things Rob where can they find you
and how can they uh go deeper if they
want more Channel reviews like this from
vid IQ so you can find me on the vid IQ
channel on a very regular basis we do
live streams every Tuesday on channels
we do video reviews every Wednesday and
I'm always kicking about in the social
medias and can I just say because I
think this is public knowledge now right
congratulations to Sean
uh the little baby boy who was um who
was born yesterday I believe so yeah
huge congratulations to the entire think
media team yes we had a new baby channel
we've got John Steven welcome to the
world so uh if you were waiting around
for the baby news the newest addition to
the think media family has arrived and
he is doing great baby's doing great
mama's doing great Sean's doing great
and uh we're just so excited for this
new little bundle of joy that's sorry
did I just spoil a lot was that like no
it's already public knowledge it's out
on Instagram if it's hit Instagram rob
it is public knowledge so Instagram and
Facebook
um I'm just trying to find it right now
because he is the cutest little baby
um looks just like his older brother uh
and if you have not heard Sean's story
um This truly is Miracle uh this baby
and um and and uh oh here we go here we
go let's share let's share because
everyone loves a good baby photo right
hopefully this gets us more views
I'll take a picture of my cute dog
afterwards and maybe that'll boost the
algorithm yeah dogs and babies here we
go this is the new addition to the
Channel family this is Baby John Stephen
miracle baby really inspiring um if you
like I said if you've heard Sean's story
before it is incredible that they are uh
you know they are being fruitful and
multiplying just as we have been
commanded to do so really excited about
that
um thank you rob for being a part of
what we're doing hey if you've not
subscribed yet to the think media
podcast you're on the channel right now
if you're on YouTube I want to encourage
you to hit the Subscribe button that
just helps us to be able to allow for
more content to go to more creators just
like you and you'll get exclusive videos
just like this with Channel reviews we
are uploading amazing content every
single week for you um as part of our
Tuesday ritual and we want you to be a
part of what we're doing here at think
media so make sure you subscribe like
this uh video and let me know what your
aha moment was from today's live stream
down in the comment section below if you
have a question you can leave that down
in the comment section below and our
team will get it or it may be a future
video that we have here at think media
thanks for watching we'll catch it in
the next stream are you looking for the
best YouTube marketing and money making
strategies for growing your online
business faster then make sure that you
are subscribed to the think media
podcast every single Tuesday we release
a power packed actionable podcast
episode where we cover the latest
Advanced strategies for growing faster
on YouTube We also bring on industry
experts and we pick their brains on how
they're using YouTube to grow their
businesses and how you can do it too you
can find us on Spotify Apple podcast and
YouTube just search think media podcast
wherever you like to listen to your
podcast or head to thinkmediapodcast.com
[Music]